I gotta ask you about Hayes man who's in  the scary accent how's he doing lately I  got a call on set and I was freaking  sorry but literally like I didn't know  what to do I've never like it's weird  when like you're a part of something  like that like you're already scared but  to get a phone call about it I was like  aha  what is this so I waited for 20 minutes  just like freaking out and I finally got  a call and he's all good he's just like  really messed up right now but yeah he's  just he's still nos abilities chillin  now FaceTime this morning I was gonna  say have you heard from him broken bones  can be fixed he's delicate though is  just a reality check  shortly after nash grier spoke with ET  he's took to twitter to share an update  with fans he posted this selfie all  bandaged up with some bruises and wrote  in the caption ready to be back